hi laura hi it's so great to see you it
is so great to see you too i am so
excited and everyone is so excited to
see you back i mean we did briefly see
you in jurassic park 3.
um so jurassic world dominion is really
your triumphant return
how much fun was it stepping back into
this character
it was amazing i have to say you know um
i was very grateful
um that when steven spielberg uh first
brought up the idea and frank marshall
and then i sat down with colin trevorrow
they were so generous in
you know a willingness for me to
collaborate and where would dr ellie
sattler be today and yeah i think what
really moved me was their openness and
and agreement that this franchise has
had environmental messaging you know
deeply embedded in it and this character
has been a true feminist from the
original film
and so their openness for her to now
evolve into soil science and focus on
climate change
in her work
and her independence and her comfort in
self would evolve as a woman uh made me
super excited
how refreshing and progressive and yes
please more of that in the universe
exactly and more amazing since our first
film in this franchise right also
powerful
strong amazing impactful women um you
know join and have joined this franchise
and we're all together in this movie
which is really exciting yeah it's a
beautiful time for sure um you reunited
with your trio with sam and jeff and
herself and and and we saw the singing
on instagram so my question to you is
when can we expect your album
oh it's coming is that we're probably
gonna drop the album same day june 10th
that the movie comes out perfect perfect
okay i love that i love that
um speaking of nostalgia shooting that
first film did you ever think that there
would be moments where pictures like
jeff with his undone shirt that posed
you know what i'm talking about oh yeah
that it would live on
this long like that people would be
using it today
i did not no on any level did i think
that nor did i understand i understood
what it meant to me
the privilege of you know of
not only the fun of it but also
genuinely getting to say a couple of
lines that felt
sadly
cutting edge right a female character in
an action film
that saw herself as
you know at least at the very least a
partner and an equal if not right if not
more
badass but i didn't know what it would
mean to others and so that that's been
really exciting because
as jeff with his open shirt is there i
you know go get the power back on to
save everybody women inherit the earth
you know yes exactly i love that so much
um everyone in this film is talking
about how much bigger it is in scope
we're merging jurassic park team with
jurassic world team and of course the
dinosaurs
um which which is scarier for you do you
think
which which dinosaur you mean or yes oh
my goodness the raptors or the gigantic
i can't even say it the giganta yeah
giganotosaurus i love you laura rescuing
me from my words
by the way because i said it just as you
did
when i originally said it on set and
colin was like that's not how you say it
so sorry colin i've learned i've learned
now um
well the giganotosaurus was there with
us in full glory as an animatronic
and it is
terrifying
so when you have um
scale
life like dinosaurs that you're acting
with you know having also done cgi on
what was the first cgi movie right i
mean there is nothing like it and as
terrifying
as scope and scale are
there is a dinosaur i won't give it away
that i deal with in this movie
that is the grossest
most disturbing creature i have ever
worked with
and it's not that big
but none of us ever want to come into
contact with it just trust me
i don't even know but i'm very excited
okay thank you and just before you go
can we say the name together teach me
gigan
giganotosaurus giganotosaurus
that's it you're a paleontologist
basically basically basically i love you
and i am so honored to get to meet you
even if it's through this but uh thank
you for everything appreciate it you too
adore you thank you so much